christina is in kansas city hi christina
how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call i have
a question about
baptized my husband and i have been
married for almost 10 years
and for the first time we are searching
for a new church family
and for the last six months we have been
setting aside our tithe and a fund
but we're not sure what to do with the
money um we're wondering if we should
just
write a big check when we find a new
church that we want to join
that'll be fine there's nothing wrong
with that uh you can find some local
churches in your area to spread it among
now if you want
um here's the thing um what we want to
do
is we want to be obedient to the
scriptures those of us that are people
of faith with our generosity the tithe
is the baseline
for our generosity but you can never
stray away from
why why does god want us to be generous
it's good for you because he wants to
make you
into a generous person and generous
people are just more fun
they're happier they're not depressed
very often they don't live in their own
heads
yeah it's not all about you they live
with us the purpose is not every jot and
tittle meaning every little freaking
finite detail about the nuances of which
scripture or whatever and god is not
going to bless that because you gave it
to a baptist instead of a church of
christ or whatever
there's none of that don't get caught up
in that uh so it
it so the point is you have set this
aside you are going to be generous
you're going to give it to someone god's
smiling he's not wringing his hands
about where it lands
because it's for you
that make sense yes that's great yeah
you're awesome i appreciate you i
appreciate your
character and your your desire to
be true to your faith and and i mean
that's just very cool that's a that's a
person who's tethered into their virtue
above and beyond experience right yeah
like i'm going to be this kind of person
whether i've got a a category to send
this to right away
this is who i am this is who we are and
changing churches man it's just it's
like
a change for some of us it's like going
through a divorce i mean it's just
because your socials tied in there
everything
oh my gosh it's hard enough that's tough
you're going through a hard thing right
there kiddo
good for you that's inspiring man that's
very neat